رغم الاتفاق مشاهدينا على تمديد جديد
للهدنه السادسه المعارك تتواصل بين الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع في اكثر من موقع
في السودان سابدا مع ولايه الخرطوم هناك
ثلاث مناطق متوتره تشهد عمليات الخرطوم
العاصمه
واندرمان وايضا خرطوم بحري في وسط الخرطوم
وتحديدا في محيط القصر الجمهوري كما نتابع
هنا حيث تقول قوات الدعم انها تسيطر عليه
دوله انفجارات وتساعدت اعمده الدخان
واستمر تحليق طائرات الجيش سانتقل الان
الى المنطقه الاكثر توترا وهي محيط
القياده العامه للجيش والقوات المسلحه
السودانيه ودائما نتحدث عن الخرطوم حيث
تتواصل الانفجارات والاشتباكات العنيفه
بين طرفي الصراع هناك هناك ايضا منطقه
القياده العامه التي تعرف بالخط الامني
والتي تضم كما تشاهدون هنا
مبنى الاستخبارات مبنى القوات البحريه
السودانيه رئاسه اركان القوات الجويه
السودانيه والقياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
ورئاسه الاركان وكل هذه ما زالت كلها تحت
سيطره الجيش السوداني اما محيط القياده
العامه فما زال يخضع لسيطره الدعم السريع
والذي يشمل عددا من الشوارع سانتقل الان
الى الخرطوم بحري كما نتابع في هذه
الخريطه حيث تشهد اشتباكات متقطعه ويقوم
الجيش بتمشيط المنطقه من قوات الدعم
السريع
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات